you are watching the press preview a
first look at what's on the front pages
as they arrive in the next half hour
we'll see what's making the headlines
with the guardian commission williams
and the pr consultant alex dean
so let's see what's on some of those
front pages for you now
the telegraph carries allegations that
boris johnson personally instigated a
leaving party for his former director of
communications lee kane during lockdown
the mirror leads with those same claims
while the times doesn't specifically
cover those allegations it does
highlight the prime minister's
insistence that he's done nothing wrong
over parties
the eye focuses on the opposition mr
johnson is likely to face over the
matter from within his own party
the mail reports on the backlash against
the archbishop of canterbury's
description of the government's rwanda
asylum plan as ungodly
the guardian has seen figures which show
that women who live in england's poorest
areas die younger than their
counterparts in almost every comparable
country
research carried out by the financial
times has found that the ongoing war in
ukraine taken together with the twin
presence of slow growth and high
inflation pose a significant threat to a
worldwide economic recovery
the sun features a royal exclusive
reporting that the duke and duchess of
sussex have hired one of barack obama's
former bodyguards
and the star features the actor brian
blessed laying into the character of mps
and a reminder that by scanning the qr
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's newspapers while you
watch us
and joining me tonight is zoe williams
and alex dean welcome to you both uh
let's start with um
well partygate which hasn't gone away
and uh it looks like boris johnson's
been implicated in one of the the
parties that's under investigation let's
look to the daily telegraph as you've
got your party headphones on there zoe
will come to you first
i certainly i'm certainly not wearing
these headphones in support of the prime
minister can i just add because they're
my daughters um
yeah look this surfaced in the sundays
um more of an inference than an actual
fact or a story and it surfaced on
social on the socials as well today so
i don't think that i don't think number
10 will be too surprised but there is
this charge that lee kane's leaving do
wasn't actually a leaving do it was more
of a kind of goodbye and then boris
johnson turned it into a leaving do by
arriving you know in full sail full of
bonami
calling it a leaving dude giving a
speech
the really bizarre thing about all these
stories is that every single alleged
party comes with an official
photographer so you do have to wonder
what on earth was going through
anybody's heads at this point it's not
as though there were no warnings from
senior members of the of cabinet office
saying this isn't a good idea but
apparently those did not percolate even
to the extent that they let the
photographer stay home so there is a
good pictorial record everything that's
going on and i would be surprised if
these kind of rather blustering number
10 denials are actually going to amount
to
full-throated denials when it comes to
it well down the street uh have not
disputed uh the description of the event
but but said it was untrue that mr
johnson had organized it
alex
yeah first of all zoey never apologized
for those headphones that are amazing
my position is that this is bad i think
this is very tricky for um number 10.
look i i hope and believe i've got a
sense of proportion i don't think we
should lose a prime minister over this i
think the reaction to this has been over
this whole episode has been overblown
but not least people seeking political
advantage the reason that it's bad is
that the explanation that's been given
to us um from the cabinet office and
from number 10 consistently has
basically been that the prime minister
was ambushed and there were a series of
of things that he couldn't help or he
was away and so forth but explanations
that seemed held up at the time and i
wanted like the rest of the country to
move on i also think that it's the wrong
time to try to uh to fenestrate prime
minister giving that he's leaving
leading us in this situation in ukraine
but
if this is the case if the prime
minister instigated
some of the celebrations then it does
seem different not because of the
coronavirus rules being breached per se
i actually think we went over the top
when we sought to um go after the pm on
that and not because of some of the
alleged activities or behavior that
people have tried to pin on number 10
but because of the explanations that
we've had that now seem to be unraveling
that in the end i think is going to be
the sticking point what's the pm said in
um parliament's what's the pm said in
response to questions that he's now
going to have to roll back on and and uh
zoe the point is also is that i think
there are about four other parties um
under investigation which the the prime
minister might have have been at so this
this is the the beginning and what
what's been reported previously is that
even conservative supporters
that could have
made do or or suffice with one fine if
it goes on to be more than one or
several then that really is the point at
which they withdraw their support
well it does become extremely difficult
because these fines are of course
compound right so if he ends up with
five fines then that's
a nice insignificant amount of money um
and that will be excruciatingly
embarrassing if indeed he is capable of
embarrassment which you know evidence
suggests that he may not be the thing is
everything i hear this line a lot at the
moment people saying well i think the
rules were stupid you know it's you know
obviously he got caught out but the
rules were stupid now that's a fine
thing to think i mean all of us at some
point may have thought i wish i didn't
have to abide by that rule or this one
but the truth is that
really the casting judgment goes with
the people who were subject to the rules
at the sharpest edge of their lives you
know losing parents not being able to
see them holding funerals not being able
to hug people
those people are not going to forget any
of this and they're not going to say
this pales into insignificance next to
ukraine they're not going to say what's
a case full of wine it was what's wine
in a wheelie case compared to a cost of
living standard crisis they're not going
to say any of those things because these
rules matter to them at moments that
they won't forget so i think number 10
and its cheerleaders generally have to
test out some new lines because this
kind of attempt a sense of proportion
which goes these were just parties and
now the world has got more serious
things don't get much more serious than
having lost a loved one during the
pandemic and that's not the
the end of the telescope those people
are looking through and alex as you say
it gets more serious for the prime
minister when we have headlines like the
mirror that
he actually led the party in this
instance
yeah look i want to address what zoe
said i've lost my father in lockdown not
to cronovirus but to cancer and we had
one of those
appallingly wretched funerals ourselves
where you wore masks and there were no
hymns and you couldn't hug each other
and it was horrible but i still hope and
believe that i've got a sense of
proportion about my country and i don't
think it would be right to lose a prime
minister over this and i do think that
it's right to try to take all
circumstances into account i didn't say
that the rules were stupid i said that
it would be disproportionate to have an
outcome that saw us defenestrate the
prime minister over some wine and some
cakes that said the reason i think this
is a problem isn't because of the
behavior it's because the explanation
that we've received throughout it now
seems to be slightly unraveling and this
often happens in political situations if
you just go at something long enough the
explanation which stood up like the
first second the third and fourth
attempt uh suddenly seems to be in
jeopardy as more facts come out and
that's the problem number 10 is going to
have now not least because many
spokesmen and defenders of the
government have been sent out with old
lines with old justifications and
explanations of behavior which are in
jeopardy because of stories like this
let's move on to the rwanda plan
and this criticism that's uh been um in
all of the papers from the archbishop of
canterbury he in turn is being
criticized by conservatives now some
saying uh very naive in the way he's uh
politicized this and brought it directly
into his his sermon zoe
um yes sorry just to say alex i'm
terribly sorry about your dad um
okay so this the funnier headline is
actually on the telegraph which says
which says that welby's been attacked
for moralizing now i think
you know he was moralizing he did say
that this plan is immoral he did say god
would not approve that's about as m
that's about as morally focused as you
get but if when if an archbishop isn't
allowed to moralize you know what or
next do you want a surgeon who doesn't
know where your spleen is he's got to
moralize that's the that's the point of
spiritual leadership now you can
disagree with kind of
the link between church and state but
not i don't think can you disagree with
an archbishop saying that this plan is
immoral just to recap the plan of course
under this scheme which wasn't at all
clear when it was first announced by
pretty patel with like with that kind of
glee in her face
under this scheme asylum seekers get
dispatched to rwanda
where even if their claims are
successful they're not successful in the
uk they are successful in
rwanda and they're resettling in rwanda
so we would if if this were real i think
it probably got an element of kind of um
strategic um overblown-ness i think it's
possible that it won't amount to as much
as it says it's going to but if this if
this scheme were real then the uk would
cease to be a place that gave sanctuary
to people escaping war that i mean it
couldn't be more serious it couldn't be
more serious what where we put ourselves
in in the
league of countries who care about other
nations to make this move so you know i
i'm kind of behind you know i'm not a
christian but i do find myself in camp
christian on this occasion
paige this article about the cleanup
that's um
beginning in in ukraine
well
of course
right now we've seen the russians tell
the ukrainians to surrender in various
places and quite rightly the ukrainians
are refusing to buckle to
their pressure so we're not going to get
to a clean up proper until the russians
have removed themselves from the
sovereign state of ukraine and their
unlawful invasion has ceased but in the
meantime there are certain parts of
ukraine that have been liberated and my
god this problem is going to be with the
ukrainians for years unexploded
munitions pollution of the worst kind
destruction of basic facilities
infrastructure in ruins and this is why
we picked this story to talk about
because what we've seen in past times is
that when the conflict stops
international attention goes away and
whilst we are helping as much as we can
right now with ukraine help of a
different kind becomes necessary and not
for months either but for years after a
conflict ends and after all if we want
ukrainians to be able to go back home
and have a home worth living in and the
millions of people who've had to flee
their home can go back to something my
gosh we're going to have to help them
not just in fighting but in peace time
as well no absolutely so it's going to
be some time before they can ever return
to any sort of normality
well it's extremely difficult as well to
figure out how best to start this
cleanup operation when you when there's
no um
you know there's no there's not even a
pause from russia there's simply then
regrouping and
ultimately
zelinski has said since the beginning
he's he's going to want reparations from
russia and he's going to want russia to
bear the cost for this so that that's i
think probably what's face the challenge
facing them is how to deal how to kind
of
bring back civilization when you're in
this limbo and you're in a kind of
financial and military limbo and you
have no idea what's going to happen next
it's just unimaginable
the decisions that ukrainians are having
to make both at kind of municipal and
personal level absolutely
we're going to change change gear uh
slightly to the daily star we don't
normally end on that paper but uh brian
blessed has a a few things to say about
our politicians alex
first being gordon's alive and by richie
brown and a return to standards he
prefers uh brian blessed thinks we
haven't got uh great politicians and
there's ways to all about him perhaps
wearing a hawkman suit i don't know um
it's saying how bad i think politicians
are and um i i for one having grown up
in the 80s just love the sight of brian
blessed he must be so bored alex people
and screaming gordon's alive as you just
did
zoe and alex thanks very much see in the
next hour